good hit on foran to free The Zo will pinch in
from the point jaru towards the goal dord makes
his first save Shabbat another shot native
of Lindy Ontario with a lot of friends and
family in the building out it ahead gour
carries it across and his shot stopped by
forsberg who makes a good first glove save
set it in Chan over skated it student each
looks back to the point long shot JS and a
good save face off will come to the right of
forsberg one cleanly by here Edward Belmar
but it's kachuck will start the other way
with it HS Norris on the near side Morris
a shot and he rips that into the glove of D
Joseph leave up the puck along the wall veneers
will start back the other way he finds McAn here
McAn is shot first foring the save rebound
popped up tereno on it first looks back to
the point kept in there on the backand by
Chan and a chance to clear can't get it
out of Seattle opportunity for kubalik blocker
save made by Dort Anderson couldn't get to him
in time gour throws it to the near side it's
bers makes it back to Dunn Dunn winds fires
that one tipped in front cour triying to dig
it free wur made the save rush to the corner
Z tried to pin it there with just 10 seconds
left in the power play St looking to dig it
free out of the scrum as well finally Everly
will it in front what a save forsberg as he
robbed for bork Strand and that will kill off
the power play of St brings it back the other
waya goes down the fans here smartly want to
call they're not going to get it and the boo
birds out quickly a shot towards the goal it's
loose and the cord reaching underneath them both
teams at an important juncture in their skill
schedules a 9 day 4 City trip for Seattle and
the start of a three-game home stand for Ottawa
here's kubalik looking across finds BS that one
is hit the crossbar oh so close he Rings The
Iron still no score in Ottawa on hockey here
is B stun tipping from in didn't get past
Sanderson them open R to kachuck they rip
it in on neck trying to fool dord who's going
to freeze it there shabat put into the corner
raon couldn't get to it t will try the near
side and now Everly out for bers bers with
some room and a shot stopped by forsberg the
whistle goes before any rebound could pop out
to the left of Anton forsberg controlled by
the senator here's kachu finds it in skates
looks it across for Shabbat Shabbat shot
deflected wide of the goal zaru onto it
first around the boards Far Side Norris leads for
it and then it flipped over his stick and mccan
will start back the other way there mccan with
bers threw it across the zone now mccan flips it
down for bers in the corner gets away from the
check bers centered out front Everly wanted to
go back hand here's done a shot in forsburg
the save starting back the other way Parker
Kelly in on Alexia and the for check otwa gets
it to the point ham cross the Blue Line comes
the sh'll rip a shot here's Duman waiting for
it set up for the one timer tolvan pulled it
back thrown out into the slot for bork strand
back for tolvan bork strand fires kick save
made by forsberg credit the own time to Yanni
gour what a pick pocket it's set in front that
one hit tolin in in the slot senators get it
to the Blue Line not out Gord again spun it
across the Zone bar side with waiting for it
was tolvanen looks back to the point finds
being stun tolvanen pulled back the onetime
now he shoots zve M trying to flip it out of
the air with Bor strand down for b d s shoot
that one stopped cross for Norris Shabbat dla
dler Shabbat his one timer into the crowd ends
up in the corner D fights off a check give it
away though borgan will get this ahead G with
Doris trying to get back in time in front M
he'll rip a shot another shot on forsberg he'll
play this ahead as he gloves it down the break
out was stunted on an A P here's a chance for CH
a shot and I'm not sure he got all he wanted on
it sends it around done looking rink wide that's
picked off nicely by Joseph and then he sent it
in off of sh couldn't Center that for Parker
Taylor here's a steal in front Joseph scores
kind of felt like both teams were waiting for
someone to make a mistake and Seattle makes
the first one you can mix up your forward
lines a little bit so Joseph gets a spin
out there with Kelly and Char and it works to
Perfection look at the patience here he pulls
the cord way over to the glove side before
waiting patiently and I love this making no
mistake about it paneers is there he's trying
to act as a goalie and Joseph was having none
of it great definition to the top part of the
net for enough to his reach to try and redirect
it past the cour gaining the zone is z closo
in front to the tip and the cord the save a
good one there minutes and 8 seconds into
the game against Columbus and then things
changed drastically well here with the one-
nothing lead not sitting back continuing to
forge forward dumlin he's looking for a tip
in front Ottawa will bring this ahead head
the other way here's stla made a move at the
line they stay outside stla again the shot the
cor way out of his net and the scramble forward
ends up along the board your Str to come up with
it back for Shabbat he gets set up here's
kubalik down low in right across the blue
ice and dord got the pad across and was able to
lock it down in time before a senator stick of
tereno could get on BYU to get across the ice
and mccan comes back to help out defensively
his stick gets in the road before tereno could
get to it and then dord eventually covers it
up taking away yet another good opportunity
thanks to a good stick defensively and that
kind of stretched can really spread it
out and that's where their success was
last year Rolling four lines coming at you
wave after wave they haven't gotten into
that mode just yet here's tereno in with
the steel freed it up here's a chance they
score beautiful passing passing play finds BS
teraso with the for check to start it off and
the Senators have a two nothing lead dord can't
quite handle it and as a result of that tereno
jumps on it and it goes from sta to BS that
little bit of hesitation trying to get back
into the net cost him completely pulled him out
of position and bson waited patiently and a lot
like earlier in the game when Joseph had an
opportunity in front of that Locker save made
the rebound here's a break and it's dla all alone
Tim SC to the net stop TI a court he ends up with
the Breakaway kicking it from skate to stick
looks back behind him to see larsson's giving
Chase tries to go to the Alexia will come up with
it behind his net though and start out hands up
on the stick of York Strand they get it across
the Ottawa light centered in in front backand
try forsberg in the full splits to make the save
and hang on and then yor strand doing some nice
work backhanding it to the front of the net
he knows he's got gourd there gourd does a
good job spinning to make his stick available
but again forsberg so good the has been like a
firing range in this game es off win by the SS
they're going to bring this ahead short-handed
here's a chance for Stow witho goes on goal what
a save reaching back by DOR even off a pass he's
got jeru on the far side but it goes off of the
stick and forces dord to go back to the glove
side 10 seconds left Everly threw it across the
crease another shot on goal that one blocked by
Sanderson in front two seconds left comes out
front big block again by the Senators it's a
shut out for Anton forsberg first of the season
for Ottawa and a two nothing win over the Kraken